[Applause]
so as many of you know years ago tarik
and i were actors at a theater called
boom chicago in amsterdam now while we
were there we did a million improv shows
and played a million improv games and we
loved it so we thought we'd play one for
you guys tonight and we invited some
friends to help us out with it please
welcome our buds from the hit broadway
show freestyle love supreme anthony teen
touch venice alley tyler taser rose
arthur the geniuses louis and tarek
tarnish heart away davis
now
after a long hiatus for the pandemic
their freestyle rap improv show is
finally back on broadway at the booth
theater isn't that exciting
that's right
tarek has a second job on broadway
that's real he's a show-off that is also
real
so we are going to play an improv game
called conducted song okay
okay
so we're gonna sing a song for you right
now but we are going to make it up
entirely 100
on the spot and you are going to tell us
what that song is going to be about so
please shout out a suggestion of any
everyday object like a blender or a hot
dog or
margarita
a oh [ __ ] someone said margarita machine
but someone else said spatula and i have
to go with margarita machine because i
see that [ __ ] in my
kitchen every day
right
the suggestion is margarita machine
anthony tarrick and i will be singing
the song margarita machine and kayla
will conduct that song while she beat
boxes at the same time
these guys can only sing when i point to
them and when i point to them they must
sing and like any good song it will
rhyme okay
okay okay a steam guess we present to
you the new hit song margarita machine
all right
all right ready arthur and five six
seven eight
come on amber
i like to get drunk dirty i like to get
drunk clean
i like to get drunk with my margarita
machine
margarita machine i have to say you
truly are the best
that's right
margarita you got me impressed
margarita drink it down
margarita drinking down you make me try
to walk like a clown
margarita oh you are so very lovely
margarita don't you know you make me
drunk and ugly
margarita i have four five and i'm worse
off than i thought
but i don't know what to do because i'm
drunk as a stone
margarita drink it down
[Music]
you better bring your margarita machine
[Music]
because
[Applause]
rat break your margarita oh damn you got
my rim salted margarita i don't know how
i'm gonna cuff it singing margaritaville
like i'm jimmy buffett
margarita who the [ __ ] is him just give
me some
[Applause]
can't do no wrong
[Music]
mcdonald makes me frown
margarita you want the toast of the town
margarita
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much to priests
please give them a huge round of
applause and please go see their
fantastic show
broadway at the movie
my voice went out
[Music]
you